thought I was shouting anyway thank you
item 1 on the agenda tonight is
apologies for absence we have received
in the office
apologies Florence's Kassar counselor
mrs. Mason counselor
Elliot Mason counselor John Mason and
counselor mrs. dune Lumley are there any
more Thank You chairman counselor Ft
can't make it this evening thank you
thank you
item tome minutes of the meeting held on
the 17th of October 2017 and of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 28th
of November 2017 we have got two
inclusions which are on the agenda so
are they approved subject to the
inclusions that are on the agenda
item three to receive declarations of
interest Thank You chairman and a non
pecuniary interest plays on six point
two in relation to Crown Hill public
toilets by virtue of being a member of
Riley Town Council Thank You Barry Thank
You chairman exactly the same section
six point two although I'm a member of
ready Town Council have not been
involved in any of the discussions
regarding the public toilets being the
portfolio holder for the environment
thank you madam chairman exactly the
same 6.2 non-pecuniary interest due to
being a member of a new Town Council
thank you
[Music]
thank you
in any discussions with the parish
council thank you cats Lippman
[Music]
Thank You 6.2 by to have been a member
of Raley Town Council Thank You chairman
I'll just say detailed 6.2 as member of
the Working Party on the right to take
care of a chairman item 61 to as a
member of ready Town Council I'm member
of raising Town Council no opportunity
interest 6.2 have I missed anybody thank
you
item four announcements from the
chairman leader or head of paid service
I think counselor cut more No
this is my announcement right I have
been to a number of different events
representing this council and our
residents I don't want to list them
because if I mentioned them individually
it would just be a list of venues and it
would not give you an understanding of
the events so but I have had the
opportunity of promoting our district
for many different to many different
people inside and outside of our area I
mean firework displays school events
Scout and young people events Christmas
lights Carroll concerts sports awards
and I have judged the Christmas card
competition which I have to say was
exceedingly difficult because I wanted
all of them to win it was wonderful to
see the children in our district
participating I also attended five
remembrance sunday services which were
very sobering events as a resident I've
attended the Ray Liam Roger had liked a
switch on in the past having taken my
children there and recently more
recently my grandchildren so I was
particularly honored that last weekend I
was privileged to help turn on the Rotch
red lights and that will be a lasting
memory for me I've always believed in
this community and it is such an honor
to meet the people that put so much into
making our community what it is we must
recognize that our district is a caring
and considerate district and we are
privileged to live here
unfortunately the Carroll College that
had to be canceled that was due to the
weather although I did receive some
comments afterwards that people were
quite pleased to remain indoors in the
warm but I was very disappointed with
that so I'm sorry about that but on the
subject of a caring community I just
would like to mention that last weekend
Christmas presents that had been bought
for children for a Christmas party in
Rockford was stolen in a burglary a just
giving page was set up with a target of
250 pounds the last time I looked that
target had reached over 900 pounds plus
a number of gifts and sweets donated so
in my opinion what a wonderful community
we have good guys 900 bad guys 1 and
that leads me on to another resident was
needed help and I will pass you over to
councillor Webb who is going to just say
something about this thank you madam
chairman many of you will be aware of
the fundraising that has been done
recently for lady in that area who
needed urgent and very expensive
life-saving surgery
Sarah Goering is a lady who was always
looked to make the best out of her life
despite her very serious medical
condition along with others in this
chamber of nine Sarah for many years in
fact she's a godparent to my two oldest
daughters she was a very positive person
who sought to help out others in the
community
earlier this year her health descended
to a new low and she was told that she
needed a life-saving operation that
including recovery time would cost 130
thousand pounds this had to be funded
privately and would take place in Spain
but she only had six weeks to raise the
money
her immediate thought was how am I going
to do this take her friends of hers in a
similar position over six months to
raise a similar amount as one of those
involved in the campaign when we started
this journey we did not know how far we
would get in our fundraising efforts all
we knew is that we needed to raise a
hundred and thirty thousand pounds to
give Sarah the chance to have her
life-saving surgery in Spain to this end
a whole range of fundraising activities
were undertaken in Rochford and I was
even sponsored on my hair a very you
keep shade of purple you can just about
see the blue tinge to it now
as the campaign gathered momentum we
were amazed to see donations coming in
from as far away as Australia and
America but what was most heartening was
how the local community of Rochford pull
together as the glue that was holding
Sarah's body stopped working it felt
like the community was holding her
together people who didn't know her
we're getting behind a campaign and
everywhere in Watford posters were up
and collection continues were out Sarah
became a local celebrity and under the
Southland airport even provided for free
flights to Spain I'm just gonna head
over to councilor Eve's now for his
contribution we we both know Sarah very
well we wanted to actually acknowledge
what has gone in here for this segment
tonight this is the point at which our
community stepped up to the plate people
from all walks of life
young and old friends and strangers
businesses churches individuals and
indeed cancers all came together to help
a member of our community in her hour of
need the fund maze raising met the
target of 130,000 pounds on the day of
her surgery exactly six weeks from when
the fundraising started this brings me
to the point of why we wanted to make
this statement many people would comment
that the community spirit was gone in
our area Sarah's situation has
highlighted is that the community spirit
in the rotifer district is alive and
well Sarah told me that shortly before
she left for her surgery abroad that
someone had spoken to her to tell her
that they had previously put a hat on
the market specifically because they
felt there was no community spirit in
the area having witnessed what had
happened for Sarah that person took
their house off of the market because
they realized that there is actually a
strong community spirit in this area the
operation in Spain was a success and
Sarah is now recovering in Spain
unfortunately she has now since had an
infection
he led to another operation and he's not
yet able to return to England
as a result of this a third operation
will be needed in about six months time
and this coupled with a significant
increase in recovery time means that an
additional 70,000 pounds still needs to
be raised to finish the treatment to the
same campaign will be relaunched in
I believe that this extraordinary
outpouring of care and concerns should
not pass by unrecognized by our council
I hope that we can join together in
expressing our pride in and gratitude to
our community in acknowledging what has
been done so far on Sarah's behalf
finally I would ask the council to join
me in sending our best wishes to Sarah
for a full recovery but she recuperates
abroad in the hope that she'll be home
soon thank you thank you Sarah was a
neighbor of mine and this event as as
proved what a caring community we have
and as I said before I'm proud to be
part of this and to be chairman of this
community is a very great honor
right item five public questions on
notice there are none item six
presentation petitions pursuant to
procedure rule 11 david miles here
would you come forward please to make
your presentation it's got five minutes
you have five minutes view presentation
okay thank you
thank you madam chairman and members
public toilets are a basic need
generally used by residents physicists
shoppers and workmen in our community
what is not visible is the distress and
hardship that can be caused by the lack
of these basic facilities for the more
vulnerable residents in effect you are
potentially preventing some residents
such as the disabled and those with
hidden medical conditions from shopping
in our village bus drivers sales
representatives and many other visitors
also rely on this facility to say as has
been said that if you need to go to the
loo you can go to a cafe or pub and buy
a drink shows an ignorance of the
financial situation of many of our
residents but you know in dignity you
are uncreate in distress my
understanding is this initiative was
first mooted by the Conservative
administration with a questionable
survey in September 2014 this took place
over a total of five hours on three
different days including appear in 8:00
and 9:00 a.m. when unsurprisingly only
one person was questioned
unfortunately the survey only indicates
the number of people that responded to
questions and there is no indication of
the total number of users in that period
however 17 visits were recorded not an
insignificant amount but nevertheless
the volume of us is not the issue here
let's be clear that the motive for this
proposal is financial has nothing to do
with helping or serving the community
the council's own mission statement is
and I quote the council's residents are
the heart of everything we do yet this
very proposal is in stark contrast to
this the claim of cost of savings per
annum is misleading when parish or Town
Council's take on the maintenance of a
public toilet the cost is merely
transferred from one Authority to
another no saving just been indeed if
you look at the capital cost being
expended to encourage parish councils to
take on the district's duties the amount
that has been committed to date and in
case any claim of savings if the
administration wanted to save money you
could do so by removing the excessive
allowances it pays to its own leader
deputy leader and portfolio holders as
something in Excel far exceeds iam
tighten to maintain our toilets parishes
should not be cajoled into taking over
district facilities to allow cost
shunting and avoid spending caps there
is no criticism of Hockley parish
council here over two and a half
thousand residents have asked to
hopefully public toilets remain open I
ask you members to respect their wishes
and lay their fears and give a
reassurance today that you will protect
the vulnerable disabled an easy wrecked
and needy residents in Lima your own
mission statement I understand that as
member for Hockley councillor he's may
be able to clarify the current situation
in closing please listen a Marine short
reassure all those worried residents the
Hockley public toilets are retained
without any closure or loss of provision
being forced on local residents and
visitors at any time thank you thank you
most of what we will be discussing
tonight is just purely and simply going
to be historical because there's nothing
that's going to change so what can this
council learn from what has happened
here there are a number of things that
in my mind have been opportunities
missed you may say and maybe on some
issues and some parts of this whole
proposal actually been somewhat
misleading to the council when we first
discussed this at Council I did actually
propose a an alternative which would
have done the aim of the exercise is to
save money not to pass money over but to
save money I gave some options that were
considered and I had actually worked up
myself which were ending up with the the
extent of savings that we were told we
needed to actually get to was this
option ever considered no I find that
quite strange really when we have our
responsibility to actually be fiscally
prudent and we are given an option of
something to consider that would give us
the savings that we're after that it is
someone who dismissed every time that
has been brought up that has been so
that's one issue historically these
figures that the council was given with
regards to the reports that we were to
discuss when we were considering the
options on the toilets one of the things
that I did question being the mag
members advisory group in particular was
the accuracy of the pricker figures that
were actually presented to the council
here now I understand that figures have
to be
presented but I would actually ask
officers counselors anyone involved at
all times if they could do their utmost
to try and be a little more accurate
sometimes in what they actually put
forward I'll give you an example the one
particular item which I have highlighted
to the members advisory group which was
in regarding and the figures which were
actually put forward on the initial
discussion regarding the money needing
to be spayed on the roof of properly
sorry of Raley ten bullets cancer cancer
sorry to interrupt but we're talking
about Hockley toilets now not really but
the other thing is we have a maximum of
15 minutes for this debate and you've
taken nearly nearly four minutes up and
there may be other ways of wanting them
yeah I got a letter I've got an email
sorry for a Marcus Haughton reads as
follows should the new toilets not be in
place this is regarding hopefully by
April next year but it is clear that
papi parish council wish to progress the
matter for example they have signed up
to an agreement to lease then as an
interim measure Rochford council would
ensure that they remained open until the
handover was finalized ten officers or
portfolio holder confirm that the hotend
toilets will be kept open because that's
a little bit ambiguous we don't really
have any certain message map
thank you yet this is a member debate
counselor so I need to hear from the
members anybody else counsel sparing
Thank You chairman if you recall we were
given that the directive too because
there is no statutory requirement for
the council to maintain public toilets
mr. Hart myself were given the
opportunity to come up with a scheme
that would facilitate the toilets across
the district remaining operational the
plan that we came up with and I take on
board their comments that I've heard so
far were scrutinized by the Investment
Board they were scrutinized by the
various parish councils and the one-five
one officer who confirmed that the
viability of these projects did stack up
and there were substantial savings to be
made with regard to Hockley as we're
talking about that at the moment the
waters have been slightly muddied in
this respect because of the involvement
in County who have blown hot and cold as
to the speed that they are going to
develop or potentially develop the
library site where the toilets are
situated we understand from Hockley
Parish Council in the last few weeks
that they have every intention of
becoming involved with your with the
maintenance of the public toilets but we
can't go any further until we get a
decision effectively from County to say
what they're going to do but there is a
willingness between both our DC and
Hockley Parish Council to maintain the
toilets but this is not open-ended we
need to know what County is doing once
we know what they're doing then we can
discuss a substantial proposal that we
could then put via Hopley Parish Council
and ourselves to the investment board to
progress a situation so that the toilets
do not get closed I hope that clarifies
the situation chairman thank you
my second item chairman I don't really
think he can fight it at all laughter
killeen castle sparrow he's doing the
best with a poor situation I understand
to put the problems here you be there
too
clarification you don't know what time
nifty it might be okay I'm still unclear
have Hockley Parish Council said they
will take over the toilets you know
Hockley and have we said depending on
the time here we as a district house
will run them until they take them over
I understand you might have a problem if
it is three years five they're still not
take it on but is that give subsequent
indication of timely that we are sort of
hoping for the moment or you're hoping
for in this thank you yes I think German
say we are in a quandary I think Hockley
you have quite clearly indicated that
they will they do want become involved
in this but until we can actually go to
them as to what is available that we can
negotiate
I think it's not open-ended I think
you'll be realistically talking a
maximum of one year that's a realistic
assessment if nothing has been
substantiated and confirmed by then I
think then we'll have to look at the
whole situation but every indication
we've had is that that will not be the
situation every indication we've had is
that a decision as to what will happen
will be in April from County and once we
know what their decision is then we can
make a suitable business case to the
investment board with what we feel is
the very what the way I hade thank you
cases very I think that's a bit clearer
um could I I'm not sure how to work this
obviously we've got three options
written down and I've
I'm not sure any of them actually fit
what we as members possibly one which is
a certainty at April the toilets don't
close immediately I know you've said
that you probably won't that probably
don't become definitely necessarily that
was all to make it very clear chairman
they will not shut in April once we know
what is going on is I keep saying we
will make whatever business case is
appropriate to the investment board to
ensure wherever possible we can maintain
the toilets in Hockley as we have done
in Hull Bridge and Riley and Rochford
thank you thank you that seems very
clear to me thank you
Thank You councillor spanner and just
just to confirm this that no decision
have be made about the Hockley toilets
until it's brought before the Investment
Board after April chairman if we're in a
position to make any views any comments
before that we get any vibes from County
any indications we will bring it to the
investment board at the earliest
opportunity it's not in anybody's
interest to prolong this agony any
longer we want to resolve it we've
resolved it with three Paris or one
Italian to parish councils we want to do
the same with the others and as soon as
we're in a position to put something
substantial together I can assure you we
will bring it to the other end thank you
happy with that anybody else
so we closed the debate now and we will
decide how to respond to the petition
counselor cut ma listen to the
prevarication by some of the counselors
here and I think the showboating that's
gone on but having said that chairman I
think the second item where we're taking
not taking any action due to the reasons
put forward in this meeting and I think
I would move that now thank you and I
second thank you so is that is that
agreed okay we will move on to item 6 2
which is the petition for Crown Hill
public toilets so it's mr. Richard lamb
born here you have five minutes for your
presentation
all right madam chairman ladies and
gentlemen members this petition is
questioning the Trent through of the
public toilets in crown Hill to Raley
town council and the building of a new
toilet and a reported cost of one
hundred and fifty five thousand before
this transfer takes place we'd public
need to be assured that this is firstly
that this is the most accost effective
solution that is why we would like to
see costings through the alternative ie
refurbish the existing toilets and
retain them as public toilet in that
site to par the running costs that RT C
of taking on known and sustainable by
them I have tried by Freedom of
Information requests to obtain this
information and they have failed to
produce a projection of costs and
whether there will be a need for a
precip increases for Raley if there is
of course that will mean a overall
increase in the council tax rule all of
railing so before any transfer takes
place this council should consider
whether it is the most cost-effective
solution for the council taxpayer and if
that needs further investigation the
council should ask the review committee
to analyze the proposal and alternatives
to be sure there is no wasting money
thank you we now start the debate and we
have a maximum that 15 minutes anybody
wish to talk on that counselor button
thank you very much airman um I'm
personally disappointed to see council
debate in this petition tonight
something I didn't think I'd find myself
saying and my disappointment stems from
a number of factors firstly as a members
will be aware of this particular
petition did not reach the threshold
whereby should be debated at full
council and whilst I fully appreciate
that a separate similar petition
attracted a greater number of signatures
that should not automatically mean that
this particular petition is also debated
at full council whilst I fully support
and respect the democratic practice of
petitioning I am concerned as a council
tonight we are setting a precedent where
even if a number of signatures does not
meet the criteria required to debate the
subject matter of full council a
decision will be taken as to whether or
not the acting is and that decision
could ultimately be regarded as purely
subjective and one that could lead to
members of the public question in this
council of motives and integrity and I
would like to suggest that the council
sticks to its council procedure rules
with regards to the handling of future
petitions with regards to the actual
number of signatures for this position I
know that there are multiple
duplications of names and therefore the
total numbers of signatures as stated is
misleading and incorrect and whilst I
stated a moment ago that the council's
approach to petitions may lead to the
council's motives and integrity coming
into question like what is a petition
that contains multiple duplications
could also be regarded as Julius it
stated in point one point four that
residents would like the refurbishment
of the existing building and continuing
maintenance under RDCs the existing
cleaning control the term residence for
the purpose of this topic is in relation
to the generous number of 977 signatures
and actually represents less than 3% of
the town's population I personally
believe that many more are not actually
concerned about who maintains because
plenteous provided the facilities are
there and they're kept clean the two
issues that most people I spoke to had
but that they did not want to see an
attractive historical building being
demolished and they did not want to lose
a much valued public convenience both
watch for district council and rainy
town counts
have worked together to ensure that
neither of these is an option and I
believe that many people in Rayleigh
will be happy to hear that
instead Rayleigh will be looking to
receive new free to use environmentally
friendly public toilets that will offer
better facilities arguably safer
environments and longer operational
times most at the same time it's hoped
that the existing building will receive
some much-needed refurbishment and a new
occupant which may benefit the town
watch for district council and Rayleigh
Town Council wasted no time in working
together to deal with the issues and
concerns that both councils envisaged
regarding this emotive subject and the
proposed outcome is favorable to both
councils councillors I have also worked
hard to ensure that the new building
offers a modern clean facility in a in a
building that will aesthetically fit
within its surroundings some members
will be aware how important this
proposal was to me personally when it
was announced I too did not want to see
or felt the need for a new facility I
too wanted the existing building to be
significantly renovated and modernized
but the truth is it's not a viable
option and the reality of pursuing that
Avenue could ultimately result in both
the loss of toilets altogether and the
loss of what appears to be a popular
albeit small town centre building
whilst I think mr. Lamborn for his
efforts in drawing this subject to the
public's attention on this occasion I
must say I'm pleased with the proposals
put forward which I believe are in the
town's been to best interest and I hope
that it will be supported by this
council anybody else folks speakers
thank you Jim bearing in mind please
that other people may want to speak and
we do only have a limited time with the
[Music]
recommendations that are on the 2.4 I'd
like to refer this decision to the
review committee to check the costumes
were done correctly please
yeah we're debating this at the moment
we can't make that's an observation we
can't make decision on that anybody else
want to speak on this
councillor Cutler chairman I'll actually
find myself as the longest-serving
member in this house now but I can
remember when we originally debated
refurbishment of the toilets at Crown
Hill and I've remember a very lively
debate where some interesting language
was used about emotions and other things
but having said that I know that when we
actually looked at the cost of
refurbishment at that time and probably
today as well because of the cost of the
fittings of fixtures and the cost of the
building itself it was actually as much
as a four-bedroom house at that time
which before unbelievable but that was
true and councilors are right in saying
the cost of refurbishment of the toilet
is an awful lot of money
well I continue chairman please cost of
a refurbishing your toilet is an awful
lot of money what we're offering the
people of Raley is continued use that
building for other purposes and
brand-new purpose-built toilets that
they will enjoy and it will be much
better to use than what we have at the
moment Chairman I would like to move the
second item on that list they're losing
my voice not taking the action requested
for reasons put forward in the debate
bearing in my chairman we've already
made the decision and you can't reverse
a decision within six months of it thank
you so does anybody else wish to say
anything and then we close the debate
all right I now close the debate and
we've got we've got councillor cut more
can you move this again please and right
and can I have a seconder
and that that that wasn't part of the
debate that was an observation sorry
sorry madam chairman that that was
really a motion to take it forward to
review council to the review committee
this is we were debating on this and
we've got a motion and we've got a
seconder so can we have a vote on that
please take a photo secondly council
couples motion then please counselor on
is seconded it so we've got a motion
we've got a seconder can we have a vote
on it please is that agreed my Morpho be
recorded gates please
chairman up I think possibly on in this
circumstance of show hands might be
appropriate so that we could see who can
we see who it's against I think we've
seen the hands hands up who's against
that is passed we're going to item seven
now members questions on notice and
there are none
number eight business from the last
council meeting there is none item
number nine to note the minutes of
executive and committee meetings held
between the period the 7th of October to
the 1st of December 2017 as noted item
10 to consider any reports from the
executive and committees to Council
number one report of the review
committee and that is counselor thank
you
members will have seeing the treasury
management material review report and
the recommendation to note its contents
I'm sure that most members will be aware
that this is one of three regular
reports that the review committee has
the chance to scrutinize with regards to
the council's treasury management
activity the report is fairly
self-explanatory however if anyone has
any questions regarding any aspect of
the report we do have no me Lucas file
section 1.1 officer and counselor Simon
Smith how did you find just in case
anyone has any questions for them and
I'm sure they'll be happy to help if
anyone has any thank you very much
are there any questions
all right so it's proposed that the
council resolves that the treasury
management media report be noted and
item 10 2 is the report the review
committee on member learning and
development counselor Western thank you
Thank You chairman membership read
reports this item is to recommend to
four counts of the decision made at the
last Standards Committee to set up a
subcommittee to look at the future
training for the next municipal year the
subcommittee comprises of four members
of the of the stands committee myself
counselor mrs. Mason Council FD and
counts the Stanley and also an
independent person Thank You Sherman
thank you any questions Thank You
chairman I don't wish to live at the
point to that recently I have been
unable to attend a couple of mandatory
training sessions through no fault of my
own or perhaps it was my fault I had it
I fell over and herself and as a result
I've been attending hospital and so on
and so forth now a number of years ago
there was the opportunity for people
like myself who had missed a training
session to do a catch-up now on I'm in
the process at the moment of applying
for dispensation so that I can
eventually either take part in the
development committee or act as a
substitute for a member of that
committee but this involves the council
in such a long-winded process but I
think that the the program for a member
learning
should be amended somewhere along the
line to take notice of this sort of
thing where members cannot attend a
mandatory training session to have a
fairly informal catch-up session rather
than going through the whole process and
a tribunal sounds like I'm on trial
thank you
any other comments chairman I think
councillor makes a good point
in as much as it is a bit ownerís if you
like to do that and of course if you're
receiving the training in any event
whether you receive it at the time or
later
I don't think makes all of it but I
think one of the things that the working
party could consider is that exact point
that he's making there so I see no
reason why the working party couldn't do
that so I'm sure that will be taken
forward chairman chairman yes that would
be fine thank you
councillor come Q so um the
recommendations are there grade
right item 11 report on urgent decisions
there are none item 12
report of the leader on the work of the
executive councilor cut off Thank You
chairman I'll see if the voice holds out
excuse me
this is the third ordinary council
meeting of the 2017-18 municipal year
and I would like to welcome all members
since the meeting on the 17th of October
the executive has met twice during which
considerations included the greater a
600% business rate pilot bid the process
for awarding voluntary sector grants for
2018-19
the quarter to 1718 financial management
and performance report discretionary
rate relief and the economic growth
strategy 2017 other matters that my
colleagues and I on the executive of
dealt with include delegating authority
to the assistant director Environmental
Services to agree sponsorship of
roundabouts that will cover costs of
maintenance and landscaping and
submitting a formal response to the
Department of Community for Communities
and Local Government cuts return on
planning for the right homes in the
right places as always check through
your chairman madam chairman I will be
happy to take any questions from members
in respect of the work of the executive
and I'm sure my executive college will
be happy to contribute where appropriate
thank you are there any questions that
noted then members
item 13 motions are notice there are
none item 14 local council tax Support
Scheme 2018-19 so it's just outlined and
the report that you have in front of you
in terms of their local council tax
scheme that's proposed for the next
financial year and I think you'll be
aware that their council is required to
set a scheme in line with them
government regulations the scheme is
essentially the same as the one that is
currently in place the only difference
is that's an inflationary uplift is
proposed in terms of the personal
allowance and and how that's calculated
for the scheme so yeah there's not not a
huge amount of change to report to the
council at this time so if if anyone's
got any questions I'd be able to take
them councillor hi
it will be in a report I have read it
and already all the readings of the
third time the words will start to blur
together all the crazy
as you say the scheme is highly complex
and I think on the matter of any
specifics I would like to take those
away and refer back to the our experts
in this field and come back to you at a
later later point but I'm happy I'm
happy to follow up any individual
queries about the scheme is so complex I
wouldn't like to give her an answer this
day are you happy with that nobody else
said the recommendation
oh sorry counselor Stanley no so the
recommendation is that the LC ts scheme
for 2018-19 be approved to come in
effect from the 1st of April 2018 is
that agreed can we be called it as
abstaining please on this item 15 is the
social media policy for members
remembers the social media policy has
been updated and amended remote guidance
to provide guidance to members when news
in social media as a communication tool
the council recognizes the increase in
so in the use of social media and
encourages the use of it
this policy is guidance for members when
using it the policy makes clear that
online activities can be covered by the
code of conduct and the guidance is
intended to reduce the risk of members
breaching their code the council has a
duty to promote and maintain high
standards of conduct by members under
the Localism Act and this policy
assistant enforcing the obligation sets
out
set out in the Code of Conduct there's
been some concerns with regards to the
policy if regarding excuse me there's
been some concerns with regards that the
policy effectively limits the counselors
to speak on council matters this policy
to make clear does not stop members from
having an opinion on council matters
whether they're in agreement with them
or not having taken into consideration
members concerns I would recommend the
additional following amendments number
one members are allowed to criticize and
challenge the council and as such these
comments are usually of a negative
nature therefore I would recommend the
removal of the word negative on page
three of bullet point number five
- choo choo choo choo -
sorry thanks Chucho
chairman at this point it's it's an
officer report to the council the
officer has got recommendations within
that report but at this point it stands
as an officer report and and they can
suggest adjustments to if they wish Jim
thank you thank you thank you and in
relation to the second paragraph on page
two I would direct I would recommend the
council delete this clause as a funnel
reflection a member can be the first I
was going to
yep thank you I think that is page 15.5
v so I think we're all a little bit lost
there but we have you found it so it's
pastry but it's 15.5 and it stuck its
yeah they use social media in anyway so
we want to take that out the word
negative out and the second one again
was during the second one is on page
fifteen point four the second paragraph
down is the suggestion that consider
keeping all my accounts as counselors
separate to that as your personal
accounts on reflection and having seen
on reflection if you're acting your
official capacity it really wouldn't
matter if you're using your personal
account or not to delete the whole
paragraph what page was that fifteen
point four second paragraph down yes you
want to delete that yes thank you Jim
thank you all right are we all clear
with that now I think any any comments
Oh counselor oh sorry
Thank You chairman mmm
first and foremost I'd like to thank our
ID for legal services for the hard work
she's put into this social media policy
and after all it is to protect us as
counselors so therefore I propose that
this council resolves opposed amendments
including those mentioned tonight so the
social media policy for members be
approved by this council thank you do
you have a seconder mr. chair I'm happy
to second that but I reserve the right
to speak at the end of the debate I
think the next person to speak was
counselor hi sorry I'm sorry I'm
slightly deaf in one ear at the moment I
think there's a severe infection playing
around I'm sharing this with fun
counselor scrutton
that mr. Stratton sorry promotion
they're different years
I think um miss Laura's been very busy
with emails from various counselors over
the last week concerning this source
early she's had emails me with me in a
conversation with me which I expressed
my concerns and one of those concerns
was around the word negative which she
has now suggested be withdrawn from the
policy I think that goes a long way to
making me happier on this
I've still got concerns that it doesn't
mention that the counselors I think
there should be a quarry tighten that
counselors have a duty to hold the
counsel to a counselor which isn't
specifically or explicitly matron given
the policy which I think it would be
with a finger to have done so and again
I would have I would have this is kind
of the choice that comes out through
counselors corresponding with MS law and
giving their two concerns I think it
would have be better and perhaps your
future it should be done such way that
there is a an open review my counselors
have which happened when this policy was
first introduced counselors were given
an opportunity to to read the policy and
send suggested changes for the policy
and I'll see about turning to counselors
I think did do that last time but at
least there was the opportunity to do it
which although there wasn't officially
this time it does appear to have
happened at the moment I'm still
debating whether or not to support the
motion disease because I simply still
don't quite as far as I would like to go
but I'll see what other members say
Thank You councillor Wilson thank you
Mary Jane um the question I've got
really is that obviously social media is
becoming more pervasive and that's what
the report says but how many complaints
have actually been made against the
count or against counselors specifically
and are there more or less complaints
being made
Thanks
council wilson i'm there's perhaps
complaints that i deal with that doesn't
come before members because having
investigated looks it might have been
made in that counselors personal
capacity so that cat that complaints
stopped at the door doesn't go any
further formally and the moment there
has been one can there has been one
complain that's progress to standards
committee and that has been dealt with
in sanctions have been laid down by the
standards committee on that i couldn't
give you a number on how many complaints
i have but we pet standards committee
there is a annual log report on
complaints received thank you madam
chairman
am i to welcome the the change that the
office has made in relation to the word
negative and that was a matter of some
concern to not only myself but other
councillors who expressed an opinion on
this i also do have a another concern in
relation to how policy should refer to
the air acts of parliament and the law
we we do reference policy to to the law
when when it when it comes into context
we've we've with that and and i think we
should potentially be looking to do this
in relation for this it has been
mentioned amongst councillors in
relation to the Human Rights Act and the
the freedom of expression and I think we
should be in our policy be referencing
to through the law in when we
when it has bearing on that policy so I
would like to have seen that there was a
reference to to the freedom of
expression as as expressed in the Human
Rights Act 1998
and also to express the view that that
councillors are you know guided by the 7
Noland principles and and that should
have also really been in in the policy
as well so that we are we are
referencing to guidance in that respects
as well so the issues that I have is
that we don't want to be ashamed being
made against counselors which which
ultimately would be a cost on the
council if it got to the point of
hearings so we should be making sure
that there isn't the opportunity for
people to do that thank you thank you
for that me to come back with reference
to council Hook ways three points in
relation to making reference to
legislation I have tried to make this
non legalese for members and easy to
understand
members were actually given the
opportunity to attend training and their
reference to the freedom of expression
and training on that was given at the
training not all policy will make
reference to legislation however I would
say that the article 10 which you're
referring to is actually not an absolute
right but qualified one and this
guidance is to help you to use social
media media responsibly so that you can
still receive the protection under that
if you there are limitations to the
article 10 human right freedom of
expression rights and if you abuse that
or fall foul of any laws or
discrimination laws that could find your
boot code that would probably you you
may I'm not saying you're definitely
will you may find that you won't be
protected by the Human Rights Act in
relation to the seven moanin principles
I would say that is already in our
constitution on page five point nine I
don't see it I need to make specific
reference to it in this policy as it
underpins the code of conduct and it's
the enforcement of the code and in
relation to dubious complaints counselor
as much I was like to stop do risk
complaints come into the council I'm
afraid no matter what policy introduced
that is not going to stop residents put
in in dubis complaints as I've said to
councillor Wilson there has been certain
complaints that perhaps new members
don't see as a monitoring officer I do
deal with and stop at the door before it
progresses to investigation stage thank
you did you want to speak counselor hi
sorry thank you madam chairman allowed
me to speak it and I was just wondering
if from counsel mrs. Rowe would consider
adding a close to her motion which may
include wordings along the line of the
Human Rights Act allows freedom of
expression this is a right for all
counselors I could see if they go by
very further she's clear she would not
accept the explicit statement there
thank you
the article ten of the Human Rights Act
is qualified
it starts off giving a right to freedom
of expression but if I may indulge for
one moment I'll read out paragraph 2 of
article 10 which says the exercise of
these freedoms since it carries with it
duties and responsibilities may be
subject to such formalities conditions
restrictions or penalties as are
prescribed by law and are necessary in a
Democratic Society in the interests of
national security
territorial integrity or public safety
for the Prevention of disorder or crime
for the protection of health or morals
for the protection of the reputation or
rights of others for prevention for for
preventing the disclosure of information
received in confidence or for
maintaining the authority and
impartiality of the judiciary I would
therefore suggest that to suggest that
the rights of freedom of expression is
absolute is misguided thank you
cancer Steptoe thank you Jeff I'd like
to thank the Angela and her team for the
little hard work that's gone into this I
know how much is it say how long it's
taken and how much work and how many
emails she's had with queries and
questions about it so thank you for that
I think the policy is exceptionally good
guidance of counsel and I'm sure there's
no counselor here that would want to
cause upset to any resident or mislead
or be racist or sexist or anything in
their things well we've got to be very
wary with social media it changes day by
day it's quicker and it's immediate and
it's always there I find it difficult to
keep up with it all and I think this is
exactly good guidance and I'm happy to
second emotion so we've got a motion and
a second subject to the amendments that
has been put through here is that agreed
anyone against you do the folks against
anyone abstaining
thank you that is that is carried item
16 now attendance at the roll garden
party does anybody want to say anything
on this
yeah Thank You chairman so so for
Rochford district council members are
currently equally eligible to attend a
wool garden party its usual for the
council to be allocated one or two
places plus guests each year and
therefore the report suggests that the
order of attendance in coming years be
agreed by drawing a random lot with
agreement to use of the Civic Car and
Driver to transport attendees to that to
the garden party so we we have here the
names in an envelope for the for the
chairman to draw if councils agreed with
that approach
the first one is I can open it
counselor Toby Mountain congratulations
second one is
councilor Griffin okay so well done
they're a bit difficult to open
councillor Hazelwood
which leaves the last one
countless ferry right that concludes the
business for tonight so I will close the
meeting at 8:30 9 I would like you to
anybody to enjoy me upstairs for
refreshments and some drinks to start
our celebration for Christmas and I'd be
pleased to see all of you up there thank
you and happy Christmas to you all